one local organization that has been hit
hard by the pandemic is teaming up with
carson kitchen
to raise funds for men women and
children affected by hiv and aids
rocky is live at carson kitchen with
more on how you can dine for
an important cause hey rocky
hey jc i know this is one of your
favorite restaurants j.c when i told him
i was coming to carson kitchen he was
very excited
so i can't wait to get to this food in a
second but first let's start
with gary here with golden rainbow just
first and tell us you know what this
means to you and what you guys do for
the community
well we provide housing and emergency
financial assistance for people living
with hiv
and in this era of covid it's really
hard to raise funds and
adequately address all the needs so
having carson kitson come out and
support us like this is just an amazing
amazing thing
so what is the fundraiser what can we do
well this year
is that you come in tomorrow and make
reservations or order
to go take out and mention golden
rainbow
a large percentage of the proceeds of
tomorrow will go to golden rainbow to
provide our
services well and so obviously you've
been on the forefront of during this
pandemic you're seeing your people
be really hit hard by this you know what
are you hearing from them and what do
they need right now
right now rental assistance and making
sure they don't become homeless
um many of our people were struggling
already before the covid
some had part-time jobs in the
entertainment industry or working on the
strip
so without any income coming in and
without an uncertainty with an
uncertainty of
where future funds are going to come
from people are really living on the
edge
and this will make sure that we can
prevent homelessness for people living
with hiv here in southern nevada
right and of course having a stable home
means you take your medicine and your
and you take better care right all
linked together thank you so much gary
so let's move over to joy now because i
want to talk about this food
and what people can eat here tomorrow to
help with this great cause
so we have a couple of our traditional
dishes here first off it's the tempura
green beans with the red pepper jelly
cream cheese
and then one of the big favorites is the
bacon jam with baked tarvardi
yes it's delicious with a baked variety
and then toasted baguettes
and then something that we offer right
now on our fall and winter menu
is our butternut squash flatbread so
it's done with the brown butter
butternut squash puree
and then as you can see all the
beautiful colors there we've got some
pears some pomegranate pomegranates on a
pizza
it's delicious and with blue cheese i
love that so what kind of food did this
carson kitchen
have what are you guys known for so
we're known for our comfort food
like stuff that's very savory american
cuisine
that's kind of been done with like a
twist yeah um so yes
we have a very eclectic menu eclectic
menu and also just a really great
atmosphere as well so make your
reservation guys call carson kitchen
you guys can also get take out tomorrow
as well to give back to the golden
rainbow all right we'll see you back
here on the floor
great thank you rocky we will check back
in with you in the 4 o'clock newscast